this video contains spoilers regarding
the hyrule warriors age of calamity demo
alright guys let's talk about breath of
the wild sequel i mean prequel i'm gonna
be honest with you guys i'm kind of
freaking out a little bit right now
because on the one hand i've been dying
to experience the backstory of breath of
the wild
like behold firsthand the events that
happened 100 years ago
you know like i talked about the other
day in this video but on the other hand
i'm not sure this is it chief i mean yes
these are technically the events
of 100 years ago i mean that's a hundred
year ago impa and 100 year ago
pura and robbie but i'm beginning to
think it may be a different set of
events than what actually happened 100
years before our beloved breath of the
wild took place
and it's all because of this little egg
dude right here sure it may be pretty
cute with its undying determination to
save princess zelda
and its adorable discount r2d2 beeps and
sounds
but don't let that distract you from the
fact that this little gizmo has the
pretty wicked awesome ability to jump
through the fabric of time itself
and that is what i and many others have
a problem with the time jumping part
and while yes the zelda universe is no
stranger to time travel
and that may just be the understatement
of the year the fact that it's happening
here
specifically may just break the entire
game's impact to the story of breath of
the wild
and if you combine the time jumping
gimmick with some other events we
witness in the demo
well it may also be creating a new great
calamity but
i'm getting ahead of myself let's back
up and break down all of these potential
issues with the story of age of calamity
so far
so after eggbot 2000 here does a front
flip into history
the first thing that was shown to us is
the tapestry this should be a very
familiar sight to any zelda fan these
days this
is the tapestry that impa in the
original game uses to explain the story
of the first great calamity
ten thousand years ago but it's shown in
the demo to actually
visibly change before our eyes and i
tell you when i saw that it made me
squint harder than clint eastwood asking
a punk if he feels lucky
eggbot 2000 just reversed thanos snaps
into existence right there on the
tapestry behind the ancient princess
and yeah it makes for a really cool
visual but here's the issue with it
the only reason i repeat the only reason
they would show the tapestry that
depicts the events of the great calamity
changing in front of our eyes would be
to indicate that those legendary events
are in fact changing as well it would be
like finding an old picture of your
family that has
oh i don't know you your mom and your
dad and all of a sudden it goes
there's like a little brother or
something you never knew you had it's
pretty safe to say that that would
change things pretty drastically
hey anyone out there with younger
siblings can i get an amen anyway back
to the tapestry i think it's safe to say
that this is
clearly indicating the game will feature
a different chain of events than that of
which we were previously acquainted with
plus the tapestry is actually about the
original great calamity of 10
000 years ago not the one 100 years ago
so that means that this is the hyrule of
ten thousand years ago and that's
zelda from ten thousand up
you know what actually i'm not going to
think too deep into that one because i'm
pretty sure
they didn't either onuma stated that he
wanted a game about the events of 100
years ago so
we're just gonna go with that until
proven otherwise the second big issue
with age of calamity story happens in
the first level and for those who didn't
play the demo allow me to summarize
briefly what happens in it the game
opens up to the king of hyrule giving
his soldiers a pep talk about the giant
hordes of enemies currently heading
their way
and how they need to you know kill them
all for hyrule
once the king delivers his final
statement the soldiers raise their
swords in allegiance and it's then
revealed that one soldier in particular
has eyes that are just too
pretty and blue to be a regular dude
because it's link
i know i know you didn't see that one
coming anyway the game seamlessly allows
you to take control of link in a pretty
smooth and impressive way and before you
know it off you go you're slicing
through a fubicablins here and a couple
moblins there but eventually you run
over beside one of the walls of hyrule
castle town and come across a very
unfamiliar familiar character impa you
find her running away from bokoblins for
some reason which is strange because
she can do stuff like that but anyway
she tosses link the sheikah slate she
was holding and it connects to the
eggbots bluetooth who i'm assuming
landed here against this rock after
front flipping into history which
wakes up the eggbot from its sleep and
then eggbot runs over to link and it
connects to the dormant sheikah tower's
bluetooth and this is where the second
issue comes in
you see it wakes up the shika tower
which then emerges from the ground
a sight that is too familiar to many a
zelda fan
here's the problem according to breath
of the wild's official lore
none of the shika towers were activated
before link wakes up a hundred years in
the future and activates them himself
we know this for a fact since zelda 100
years ago is shown to be unable to
activate
any of the sheikha shran's terminals
across hyrule a feature that is only
unlocked
once link himself activates the first
shika tower
100 years in the future and zelda was
trying to activate the shika shrine
terminal
after link had already been chosen as
her night which would have been
after these events shown here in age of
calamity since link has not been
appointed her chosen night yet
this means that this shika tower could
not have been activated at least not in
the backstory of the original game
this is a completely new event caused by
something completely new
introduced to the past the next
potential issue with age of calamity
story is actually something i called out
before the demo was even announced
and that is the appearance of master
koga i go into this in much more detail
in this video here which is linked in
the description but
to briefly summarize i believe this may
be the same master koga from our current
timeline of breath of the wild who
somehow
also traveled back in time and since
we've now been shown that there are at
least
two eggbots with the powers of time
travel one on the sheikah side and the
other potentially on the yiga's side
master koga being sent back in time also
seems pretty plausible but this would be
again a new element introduced to the
past that
was not a part of the original game's
past finally i believe
robbie deciphering eggbot's images of
the great calamity to come
and then showing them to zelda directly
is also
another huge potential issue since zelda
now sees
exactly what's gonna happen and through
her newfound determination and knowledge
of the future
may lead her to do things differently
this time around as far as i can tell
these are the only issues with age of
calamity so far
but what this all implies is actually
pretty huge because this game could
still be canon you see but in a way that
makes it non-canon i know that sounded
confusing but hear me out
if the events of breath of the wild
happen as we know they do
and on the night of the calamity when
everyone dies zelda's power
awakens the eggbot that could have
definitely happened 100 years ago since
nobody was around in zelda's room in the
castle to see eggbot front flip into
history there's no way to disprove its
existence from the initial game since it
would have been in zelda's room boxed up
the whole time
while she's struggled to find her inner
peace and once it does
enter the past and the events of age of
calamity begin to unfold
who's to say that isn't canon either but
here's the dealio
and the point of this entire video with
all of the new additions and alterations
to past events that we
know happened differently the first time
this could mean that the great calamity
will have a different
outcome this could be a new great
calamity one that we actually win
which would mean that the original
breath of the wild doesn't take place
but it also doesn't matter since this is
technically a new timeline which is why
i said a little bit ago that age of
calamity could be canon in a non-canon
way
and that is my idea on how age of
calamity could introduce us to a
new great calamity with results that
we've never seen before
and it really is all because of this
little time-hopping eggbot that is
destined to cause debates up until the
game's release later this month but what
do you think
is this really a new great calamity or
are these actually the same events that
happened 100 years ago and everything is
still canon
or something else really let me know
whatever ideas you may have in a comment
below
speculations are getting pretty wild
these days also huge thanks for watching
this video
if you enjoyed it please consider
dropping a like so youtube can spread
the love around
and build the hype and if you are a
fellow human being with a love for these
games please consider subscribing to
help grow the channel
humongous thanks as always to my
supporters of which i have two new faces
to introduce
say hello to twilight wolfo and test
type who have both joined the ranks of
my elite right here on youtube if you're
interested in helping me put food on the
table and you're in a position to
comfortably do so
please check out that join button
located below or the links in the
description to find out how also down
there are links to my social media pages
so come follow me
on twitter that's all i've got for this
one folks so as always i hope you have a
great rest of your day
and hey smile the holidays are coming
this is massington of bandits signing
out
[Music]
you